to try to get some more answers let's
bring in former CIA CIA deputy director
and CBS News senior National Security
contributor Michael Morrell who joins us
now uh Michael you know uh the Intel
World better than anyone else we could
have on this broadcast so I am curious
to know over these past two weeks with
the Chinese spy balloon and now these
three unidentified objects where does
your mind go what are you thinking
so Tony um good morning
um I'm thinking that we may have three
different reasons here why the Chinese
may be doing this
um one is obviously intelligence
collection of sensitive military sites
but I think a second is political we fly
many
um surveillance flights intelligence
collection flights not over China but
near China the Chinese can't do that
they don't have military bases close
enough to the United States so I think
they're sending a message here that look
we can spy on YouTube
and then finally I think there may be a
military purpose we can't discount that
they may be considering that should we
ever go to war that this might be a way
to deliver weapons can't forget that the
Japanese sent nearly 10 000 balloons
toward the United States during World
War II that carried incendiary devices
so I think there's probably multiple
multiple things going on here
well there's a lot to be concerned with
in that statement there the potential
for a military weapons something to
deliver a payload but I want to go back
to the spying question first what could
they pick up from that altitude with
this type of device
uh one of the things you hear right is
that they might not be getting any more
intelligence from these balloons than
they get from their spy satellites but I
think we can't assume that their spy
satellites are as good as ours so they
may be getting photographs uh better
photographs than they can get from their
spy satellites and they may be picking
up what we call signals intelligence
that would be electronic emanations
right
um that would what part and part allow
them to better Target their spy
satellites so multiple things they could
be collecting
Michael I know you can't go into
specifics on the intention of both sides
and you touched on it a little bit but
how does what U.S does with their
surveillance compared to what China has
done
Nate um nobody should be surprised that
both countries spy on each other
um we are very aggressive in spying on
them in a variety of different ways the
one I mentioned is the one that is
probably the most aggressive that
probably bothers them the most which is
flying surveillance aircraft very close
to their airspace not Intuit but very
close they often respond to those
flights by bringing Fighters close
um so a variety of different ways right
these are adversaries we're in sort of a
cold war a lot of intelligence
collection going on
Michael Morrow we appreciate you this is
very confusing so it's great that you
can help us digest all of this thank you
so much